a wrinkled old drunk ass oh lord are you
in love with tate duh i'm not dead does
everyone think you [ __ ] want him this
is getting kind of annoying
you better hope top g don't see this oh
we're actually in his last youtube video
on tape speech the internet is obsessed
with andrew tate
so this is what it is
like youtube channel's talking about
tape it's his this is his youtube
channel this is his youtube channel it's
kind of cool
overall
he was gonna get an eight he's down to
at least a seven
oh they did they cut it off before he
said six
he's at least a seven you're a six tate
according to six i gave you a six let's
keep it real tight that's too funny nah
i wonder if you watched that video
that's pretty hilarious somebody on his
team did he probably didn't that it's on
his channel now he's got minions well
let's get into the [ __ ] video alright
so guys
we you know since i'm the top g at
everything i do the first youtube video
i make goes viral i'm an algorithm
wizard i know and we got a lot of insane
comments to say the least uh people were
saying some pretty crazy [ __ ] so let's
get into it some people love you
some people hate you
who knows what tate thinks you too maybe
we'll get to meet him one day that'd be
pretty dope sure i think his mom
just to admit to the force getting right
into it i think his mom just admits to
the world that she belonged to the
streets that is that is nice and that is
something that they would never say in
person you know thank you
zork thank you thank you zork i am i'm
from canarsie no it belonged to the
streets means oh does that mean it means
you were like
like a street walker like a hoe yeah it
means you were like a hoe like oh that
[ __ ] belongs to the streets well thank
you anyway because my interpretation is
a compliment that i come from you know a
nice blue crowler neighborhood and i get
stuff and i understand life his meaning
is silly we just hit 900 subscribers oh
that's awesome thank you everybody like
subscribe and dm me proof on instagram
i'm giving a few people a hundred
dollars so go do that right now as we
continue the video so before i respond
so i'm gonna need you to translate into
modern day english because clearly i
don't know what the hell any of these
people are saying
he's top g forever oh thanks blaze yes s
blaze your mama's top w you're blessed
now go to the gym
after you walk the dog
she thinks romania is in the u.s yeah
you women am i right come on
what
240 this this dude you got to go get
some [ __ ] bro what are you doing
sitting on youtube videos writing
paragraphs maybe he's a good writer did
you read it no bro two forty-five many
things oh that's when okay that was when
he asked like read it maybe it's good it
can be edited a woman with high body
count is broken mentally physically
she's broken
um
mentally physically and emotionally and
so if you're a dude and decide to date
her you have to deal with the problems
that goes with it wait hold up
stop
typically
it does point to daddy issues 100
okay
it creates hook-up culture that is toxic
that messes with your mind
um i just think it devalues uh what it
means for a woman to sleep with someone
so she sleeps with 20 people and then
she sleeps with you it doesn't mean
anything that she sleeps with you but if
she only sleeps with two people and then
you're like the third it actually means
something yeah that's a big thing
men wouldn't want to lock that's open by
many keys he's doing the
analogy which is not totally wrong
you know that one right where it's like
a master key is one that can open many
locks but a lock that can be opened by
many keys is a [ __ ] lock
that's like an eighth grade thing okay
awesome video love the connection
between y'all too that's sweet
making a review oh it's cute making a
review video with this mommy
you probably won't talk to your mom dog
agrees with not showing emotion and
making decision gets super pissed off
when talks about not going to parents
funeral because kid is next to her and
doesn't want him to think like that yeah
no it's because i have family values
paulo
and i believe that you should show up
for your family care about your family
and stay close
no matter what and rituals
i i don't i can't think of a culture
where the funeral ritual ritual isn't
important she totally wants him
who doesn't want teeth yeah that's
stupid comment
duh i'm not dead are you in love with
tate
uh no she was like a 100 that gets angry
when tate doesn't let his emotions
influence his decision
he writes out everyone's really mad
about the funeral i know why like that's
that's what people really
got ticked off about
they're saying that you know i can't get
emotional but i'm allowed to get
everyone should have some emotion in
their life tate has an emotion even if
he says he doesn't of course he does
he's a human being and someone that's
totally emotional emotionless is a
sociopath i like this one expansion i
like your mom bro she seems cool as hell
not in that way at all i like the video
just to see the bond you guys have i
like i love how he clarified not in that
way at all thanks andre what a guy andre
jones you rock thanks if your girl goes
out at night without you it's not okay
she's for the streets and for the
streets she shall remain okay then she's
a woman why would i respect her
[Music]
good luck this is why you only have 800
subs i only have 800 subs because it was
my first youtube video
thanks for watching fbi yeah
oh this one's hilarious the mother isn't
saying it but she's heartbroken and very
concerned that she might be losing her
son
you can see it in her body language and
you can see the pain in her voice this
is what andrew means when he says the
western world is a failed society you
know
i don't like to toot my own horn but i
think i'm doing all right
i've generated five million dollars i'm
financially free college dropout i say
i'm doing all right hey wait back up i'm
doing all right too and it's not my
fault if the western world is failing we
got problems but we're going to take it
back don't you worry what was his name
a lot of you guys just found out about
me probably from these videos but i run
multiple businesses on the side at 18.
uh bro you were a [ __ ] geek and a
nerd
that's not nice aaron ling
and somebody said so what good for you
thank you
go get some [ __ ] bro dude who's who
who says that like who gets so mad from
a youtube video that you literally go
and type out you are a [ __ ] geek
and then you you read it and you're like
i'm gonna post this with my name on it
what are you what are you doing bro
that's so weird i honestly feel bad for
that person because like who would ever
even think to comment like something
like that and that doesn't even if that
if you let that hurt your feelings like
i don't even know what you're doing the
guy
yeah the guy doesn't even have his face
attached
get your in-cell ass out of here if you
look up to a guy like this you're
focused on the wrong [ __ ] in life
[ __ ] woman and being the man is not
cool if being the man isn't cool then
what is being cool being the man like
literally means being cool i don't even
understand that i don't disagree with
this guy i just don't like his i don't
like his uh attitude about it and i
don't like his tone he's he's not nice
about it if he wants to teach people
that being a man's not cool that there's
other ways to be cool he should go about
it a totally different being the man is
cool
you're the man it is if you're you're
the man the man is a decent person you
we all have different ideas about what's
cool
you're just a terrible
person who exploits loser men
who will never be in a good relationship
to be rich you can join his pyramid
scheme and jerk off a thousands of other
losers who have to do these stupid
courses to get rich nature won't be
alone oh my god i'm not trying to defend
hu like to i i don't even have it but if
you're going to call like a 50 course a
complete scam when he's actually like
providing value and then you'll pay 50
000 a year to go to college get a
business degree from a professor who
doesn't make money and doesn't have a
business then uh you're kind of
delusional i'm not trying to kiss his
ass too much but that's just the way i
feel yeah because when i'm launching my
own online university of how i've
generated five million dollars at each
18 and i'm putting like a lot of time
into it you know i'm not
i'm not freaking jerking off i mean yeah
i mean i haven't seen it i'm excited to
see it and i um if it doesn't have a ton
of like meat on the bones i'm going to
push you to make it better
yeah i mean of course it's a monthly
thing so you want people to continue you
want to provide enough value so people
stay it's not like it's not a scam i
think you're better off buying multiple
courses than going to college and doing
you can learn more for free on youtube
and reading books taking courses from
people who have what you want which is
the way i look at yeah i think you're
right your mom seems like a cool lady
but she goes on by feeling
for this [ __ ]
you're not cut out like that yes i know
mom please forgive me all right so
you're not cut out like that we can pop
up the clip real quick i wish i had
these problems
no it's no
you're not cut out like that i know you
like to think you are but you're not oh
yeah when she said you're not cut out
like that you got to imagine this is my
first time filming a youtube video with
my mom
my first youtube video we're sitting in
front of the screen and she's like oh
yeah you're not cut out like that to
have a bunch of girls like what what am
i what do you what do you expect me to
do be like actually mom i have all these
[ __ ] you want me to show you you know
you just you just keep it moving that's
funny because that's not even what it
meant
like you meant like you're not cut out
like to be a to be a dude that just
plays with a bunch of different girls
emotions i think you're a more decent
guy than that yeah that's i mean in the
past i've liked having more things with
girls but then they're all evil at the
end of the day so there's no point
prove her wrong my boy
that's funny
tate verbally destroy your mommy with
his first statement should probably
start crying don't even think to put him
in front of her
look at this he's got a picture of his
big old back he's very serious this guy
yeah okay
like excuse me please but what call of
qualifications does your [ __ ] mom
have to rate him i mean it's no
different than picking a random beggar
from the street and telling him to watch
the video and give his remarks he's not
wrong yeah i never said i was qualified
or that i have any right to judge
anybody everybody you're the one
watching the video it's funny because
we're doing this just for fun and he's
then judging me and saying i have no
idea who are you to judge her on now
it's judging tate like it's
so silly silly ghost your mom is cute no
offense though why would i take offense
why would i take offense to that it was
a very sweet comment before i get my
looks dog come on
surely you don't have a dad yourself
he's getting milk bro
yeah dad's doing all right my dad's
getting the milk don't worry about it
got a great dad no problem there
2011 i was living in new orleans i had a
roommate who was doing drugs and
overdosed i was talking on the phone
with the 911 emergency people the
operator asked me to give cpr to him
and i said hell no
nutty bandit i feel ya is your mom
single
no none of your business
the way when your mom says what you
gonna do if your son's a nerd she
talking about you you need to move out
bro dude he's 18. calm down i am moving
i'm actually moving to miami later this
year yeah i know but i don't know i keep
making you nice sandwiches maybe you
stay
keep the sandwiches and keep doing my
laundry [ __ ] this woman does not
understand anything
and your the name of your youtube
channel is hamster help okay you got you
got life down w mom what a beta and or
did mommy not agree with you you're too
much of a [ __ ] to even comprehend it
are you going to sleep all right tonight
after reading that i don't know i don't
know if i'm going to be all right after
i'm in my room in the middle of the
night crying
hooked the mom up on a lie detector
[Laughter]
you're funny i'm cast
i'm watching this channel for your
mother
okay thanks man does everyone think you
[ __ ] want him this is getting kind of
annoying
exactly jesus she thinks she can fix him
i don't want to fix anybody
oh lord and he called me an old moose
guy called me an old woman no these are
so funny
look at the way she attacked her son
when he could see both sides looks like
she wanted to hit him and start
screaming she must be an alcoholic five
minute video but she had to be drinking
her own son got sick of her and lied he
had to go walk the dog so he could get
away from her wrinkled old drunk ass
look what i said i go dog who pissed in
your cheerios
there's no way that's even real you are
just butt hurt because i see right true
i have to walk the dog [ __ ] the walk the
dog [ __ ] was a joke
about it was a joke about something else
it was like the cook the fries thing
yeah it wasn't that i had to do
something
her wrinkled old drunk ass that is the
funniest one it was really fun that you
know what look at this
it's empty i drank it all cheers to you
[ __ ] drunk dude
wow he made my day i can't even believe
that
that's so funny next time you do this
talk way less and let your mom speak
first that's why she sees that video
yeah not only did i barely talk it's the
first youtube video who says this is
this is like don't influence or lead
your guest i'm not a guest on his mother
he's a guest in my house
no you're not not really not really you
know what i don't want to hurt you
fields you know what i'm saying you
don't have feelings you're a man i can't
get over the wrinkled drunk ass that is
the funniest comment everybody
[Music]